[Musique]
bonsoir tedx coulvain nous sommes 51 5 %
de la population du burkina faso
pourtant elles ne sont que 10 à
l'assemblée nationale représentant ainsi
23% de la législature actuelle de 0 43%
des maires au gouvernement 6 femmes sur
33 soit à peine 18% et même dans les
professions libérales
il y a trente cinq femmes sur 100 98
inscrits au tableau de l'ordre du
burkina faso soit à peine 17% il pour
tailler des lois en notre faveur
par exemple la loi 0,10 tirait 2009 par
la haine portant fixation des quotas
lors des élections législatives et des
élections municipales au burkina faso
cette loi prévoit que les partis
politiques lorsqu'ils déposent des 10 de
candidats c'est d'histoire comporter au
minimum 30% bhl de l'un ou de l'autre
sexe
on pourrait donc imaginer des listes
électorales avec 70% de femmes et 30 %
d'hommes mais selon les statistiques du
ministère de l'administration
territoriale et de la décentralisation
lors des élections législatives de 2015
au burkina faso seulement 33% des partis
politiques ont respecté cette
disposition
on peut se demander pourquoi ces partis
qui n'ont pas respecté la disposition
législative donc les parties en défaut
n'ont pas été sanctionnés mais cela à
mon avis est certainement l'objet d'un
autre tête il reste beaucoup à faire
pour permettre aux enfants du burkina
faso et en particulier aux jeunes filles
d'arriver dans les salles de classe mais
mon propos n'est pas celui-là ce soir la
question qu'on se pose en tout cas que
je me pose est de savoir pourquoi
parmi des filles qui on a la chance
d'aller à l'école
celle dont les parents ont fait
d'énormes sacrifices
voulant permettre d'avoir une éducation
formelle d'obtenir des diplômes
universitaires
pourquoi celle-ci décide de ne pas aller
au bout de leur potentiel oui elle
décide et on le verra ce soir
je me nomme thompson coup dit manning
et je suis avocat ce soir dans le cadre
de la conversation que nous avons la
question que nous nous posons est
d'identifier les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer les femmes qui souhaitent
voir progresser leur carrière occupé des
postes de responsabilité occupé des
postes de leader mais avant de
poursuivre mon propos j'aimerais juste
préciser ceci je ne juge personne et
surtout pas les choix que chacun d'entre
nous peut être amené à faire
la réussite à mon avis ne s'évalue pas
en fonction des revenus qu'on peut avoir
ou encore du poste aussi prestigieux que
l'on peut être amené à occuper
non à mon sens la réussite est
éminemment personnel et sid et si on est
en paix avec les choix que l'on a fait
si on est heureux à mon avis on a réussi
dans le cas de la conversation que nous
avons ce soir
la question est donc d'identifier les
freins et partant les conseils que je
peux partager avec vous au regard de mes
quelques années d'expérience afin de
mitiger difficulté qu'il y a d'être à la
fois femme vivant au burkina faso et
aspirant à occuper des postes de leader
des postes de responsable et ce soir
j'ai trois conseils à partager avec vous
mon premier conseil
sachez qu'ils vous êtes combien d'entre
nous savent vraiment qui ils sont sans
rentrer dans un débat philosophique
autour de la question en tout cas autour
de l'expression grec connais toi toi
même à mon avis peu d'entre nous savent
vraiment ce qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils
aiment moins
ç'a vraiment quels sont ceux qui les
motive ce qui les passionne
quelles sont leurs forces quelles sont
leurs faiblesses
mais comment faire progresser carrière
lorsqu'on ne connaît pas ses talents et
ses compétences
qu'est ce qui te passionne qu'est ce qui
te motive tête de l'édition que nos
parents nous posait régulièrement à la
maison à ma soeur à mon frère et à moi
même
schappert cher mr vous avez la lourde
tâche d'aider votre enfant et en
particulier votre fille a formé son
identité à savoir qui elle est mes
soeurs si vous n'avez pas eu la chance
d'évoluer dans un milieu familial dans
lequel on vous a amené à vous poser ses
questions
il n'est jamais trop tard et vous avez
l'obligation morale envers vous même de
trouver les outils pour apprendre à vous
connaître à connaître vos talents et à
connaître vos compétences et vous pouvez
toujours faire recours à des
professionnels
si besoin est vous devez aussi apprendre
à connaître ses talents masculins ou
féminins qui constituent votre réseau
mais de ce que l'on peut dire au burkina
faso des femmes ne sont pas toujours en
compétition
rappelons-nous cet ensemble qu'elle
organisait la vie familiale ensemble
quelle éduquer leurs enfants ensemble
qu'elle assurerait la pérennité et la
transmission des valeurs et ce réseau de
soutien féminin continue à exister même
dans le milieu professionnel dans ma vie
des femmes ont souvent été un moteur de
développement
mon maître de stage était une femme elle
m'a beaucoup aidé et conseillé
encourager merci à toi natacha mon
réseau de clients se développe grâce au
soutien de femmes qui ne voient pas en
moins d'1 compétition mais une soeur en
qui elle croit et qu'elles peuvent
encourager alors chercheur apprenez à
vous connaître et choisissez de vous
entourer de ses talents masculins et
féminins qui seront vous inspirer
vous guide et vous conseiller lorsque
vous en aurez réellement besoin
mon deuxième conseil sachez ce que vous
voulez il ya quelques temps la fille
d'un ami est venu au bureau
elle étudie en droit il souhaitait voir
avec moi dans quels domaines et devait
se spécialiser je lui ai alors proposé
de rêver avec moi je lui ai dit imagine
qu on est dans un monde parallèle et que
je suis le génie de la lampe d'aladin et
que j'ai le pouvoir de te donner la
carrière de tes rêves que veux tu être
elle m'a alors répondu à temps dit comme
vous me connaissez bien et vous savez ce
que je veux faire un peu peut-être que
vous pouvez mieux me guider j'entends
des ir je vois pas vraiment c'est une
réponse que vous avez certainement déjà
entendu ou que vous êtes vous avez
peut-être été amenés à donner
ce qui m'a frappé et non étonné c'est
est de constater que cette fille comme
la plupart des jeunes que j'ai la chance
de rencontrer ne rêve plus les jeunes
filles de 15 à 25 ans que je le plaisir
de rencontrer ne savent pas ce qu'elles
veulent faire de leur vie
professionnelle
mes soeurs il faut sortir de ce mauvais
rêve
il faut que vous appreniez à rêver à
rêver beaux arts et grands arrivé en
couleurs sinon comment pourriez-vous
atteindre quelque chose que vous n'avez
pas rêvé
si vous n'avez pas une vision de ce que
vous voulez être demain de quel poste
vous voulez occupé comment allez-vous y
arriver ma mère quand on était plus
jeunes demandait régulièrement à macérer
à moi ce que nous voulons être demain où
voyez vous quand vous aurez 30 ans 40
ans 50 ans que voulez-vous faire dans
cinq ans dans dix ans teinté les
questions que nous a amenés à nous poser
que nous a permis d'identifier au niveau
professionnel
la carrière que l'on souhaitait mener 6
me demandez aujourd'hui ma mère est u ou
tu espérais être à ton âge bobson je lui
répondrais moment dans la forme non
adolescente je ne rêvais pas d'être
avocat cela a été un choix de carrière
qui m'est venu par la suite mais dans le
fond je lui dirai oui je suis avocat
soucis dans un cabinet d'avocats j'ai la
grande opportunité de pouvoir choisir
mes dossiers
mes clients j'ai un immense plaisir à
faire ce que je fais et je me lève avec
bonheur tous les matins pour aller au
travail
je suis heureuse et soit ma définition
en tout cas dans ma vie j'ai réussi
merci maman pour c'est cet encouragement
en 2016 j'ai eu la chance de participer
à une réunion organisée par un des
clients qui est présent sur la totalité
du continent en tout cas dans une
quinzaine de filiales
la réunion se tenait en ouganda et était
composé essentiellement des directeurs
généraux des filiales accompagné d'un
directeur administratif et financier et
des lecteurs équipe d'avocats
sur la quarantaine de personnes que nous
étions pendant ces trois jours de
réunion j'étais la seule femme quels
sentiments j'avais oui de la ferté d'un
fierté parce que certainement ma
compétence des reconnu et j'étais dans
cette salle mais je me suis également
dit qu'il reste beaucoup à faire pour
que ce genre de réunion ne se tienne
plus avec seulement une personne une
femme dans la salle
soyons donc comme ces jeunes enfants du
cp garçons que j'ai rencontré il ya
quelques années et qui répondait à ma
question à savoir ceux qui voudraient
faire quand ils seront grands présidents
ambassadeur pilote médecin soyons comme
eux rêvons et apprenons à nos fille à
rêver afin qu'elles ne répondent plus à
ma question uniquement en dix ans
infirmière institutrice mais pourquoi
pas président du faso
lorsque nous avons rêvé lorsque nous
avons notre vision nous devons oser agir
de quoi avons nous peur de l'échec
il n'y a pas d'échec juste un processus
d'apprentissage par lequel on apprend à
mieux faire les choses
lorsque je cherchais mon premier emploi
j'ai envoyé plusieurs cv pas un pas deux
les parents n'ont pas intervenu j'ai
envoyé une cinquantaine de cv et à
s'interroger
j'ai appris à améliorer le cv à mieux me
présenter lors des entrevues
effectivement une entreprise a fini par
me donner ma chance
les filles puisque garçons ont tendance
à prendre le rejet comme un rejet de
leur personne et nous devons changer
cette attitude nous devons aussi osé
prendre la parole dans le cadre
professionnel ou familial
je note que des femmes disent qu'elles
sont dans une salle avec des hommes ont
tendance à laisser prendre la parole
d'abord la préséance aux hommes et
peut-être par éducation peut-être par
tradition on nous a souvent dit que le
rôle de la femme est un peu en arrière
on nous a aussi dit que le chef
lorsqu'il disputait avec ses notables
sudam à palabres c'est souvent que la
nuit porte conseil et que les conseils
consistait à demander son avis à sa
femme et qu'il entonnait compte pour
rendre sa décision mais dans le cadre
professionnel
comment voulez vous que ceux qui ont la
charge de faire la promotion de votre
carrière
puisse le faire si ces personnes ne st
pas qui vous êtes jeune sympa ce que
vous pensez mes soeurs osé prendre la
parole il n'y a pas de questions idiotes
en 2003 je venais à peine de travail
depuis une semaine dans un centre de
recherche et le directeur est venu dans
la salle et nous a demandé de mettre nos
noms dans un petit chapeau je venais
d'être recruté mais je lui ai quand même
demandé si j'avais le droit de mettre
mon nom c'est alors qu'il m'a dit qu'il
ne faisait pas de discrimination j'ai
donc mis mon nom et le hasard lui disons
qui fait parfois bien les choses a
permis que
mon nom et je venais d'être choisie pour
faire partie de l'équipe qui devait
présenter des travaux du centre lors
d'une conférence à sydney en australie
devant un parterre de 300 imminent
professeurs cette expérience a été
crucial en développement de ma carrière
osez donc si martin luther king n'avait
pas eu un rêve peut-être qu'on aurait
fallu un prise en noir aux états unis il
faut donc rêvé rêvé beau rêver grand et
agir et mon troisième conseil pour ce
soir choisissez votre conjoint le
mariage d'une valeur importante au
burkina faso est certainement dans
d'autres pays
les petites filles ne savent pas quels
choix de carrière elle veut l'embrasser
mais elles savent qu'elle veut se marier
elles connaissent le lieu la chanson
d'entrée le palais que leurs copines
fera oui je vous entends rien et c'est
vrai et soyons clairs je ne juge pas je
suis moi même mariés très heureuse dans
ma vie de couple
mais force est de constater que très
souvent le conjoint épouse et devient un
frein et non à un moteur au
développement d'un carrière d'une femme
je me souviens de cette jeune fille que
j'ai rencontrés dans l'association dans
laquelle je militais ya quelques années
une fille brillante intelligente qui
commençait à croire en aide et en sa
capacité à impacter positivement son
environnement
cette jeune fille évidemment c'est me
éclore et son changement n'est pas
passée inaperçue et son petit ami
d'alors lui alors demandé de choisir
entre l'association et la relation est
mal en demandez mon avis je lui ai dit
qu'il était difficile pour moi de
choisir à sa place mais
sachez une chose si la personne avec
laquelle vous voulez vous engager ne
peut pas se réjouir de voir changer
évoluer positivement
il sera difficile point de vous
accompagner lorsque vous aurez des
promotions au niveau professionnel
et pour la petite histoire cette fille
tellement brillante a fini par avoir une
promotion et les difficultés à accomplir
ses missions se sont évidemment réaliser
puisque le petit ami d'alors étaient
devenus mari vous ne pourrez pas avoir
du succès et une vie de famille si vous
n'avez pas un conjoint qui partagent vos
idéaux qui partagent notre vision dans
la gestion familiale et dans l'éducation
des enfants dans le cadre de mon travail
je fais beaucoup de financements on est
parfois amené à travailler très tard on
a des transactions qui implique des
bureaux qui sont sur plusieurs fuseaux
horaires donc en même temps des bureaux
sur vancouver montréal londres à ouaga
et des fois l'australie et donc nous
sommes obligés de travailler
des fois jusqu'à minuit 1h 2h du matin
le succès n'est pas le fruit du hasard
il est de mon avis de ceux que je
fréquente le résultat de nombreuses
heures de travail et vous ne pourrez pas
faire de nombreuses heures de travail
si vous n'avez pas le conjoint qui vous
supportent qui vous accompagnent alors
heureusement au burkina faso la plupart
des femmes peut choisir son conjoint
fait le bon choix
le banquier faso est un pays avec ses
contraintes socioculturelles
mais force est de constater que malgré
ces contraintes des femmes et elles sont
certes pas nombreuses mais il y en a
arrive à occuper des postes de
responsabilité important à jouer des
rôles de leaders donc chacune d'entre
nous peut si elle le décide
et si elle veut occupé ces mêmes
fonctions
un pays le burkina faso en pleine
mutation et ses mutations entre un monde
traditionnel et un monde moderne soulève
des défis importants mais des défis que
nous devons transformer en opportunité
je crois que l'on peut choisir sa vie et
que l'on peut donc choisir sa carrière
mais pour ce faire chacune d'entre nous
doit savoir d'abord qui elle est chacune
d'entre nous doit savoir ce qu'elle veut
et chacune d'entre nous doit faire le
choix du bon conjoint celui qui sera le
moteur et non le frein au développement
professionnel
mes soeurs la balle est dans votre camp
je remercie